>>> WE HAVE SOME BREAKING NEWS
IN OUR POLITICS LEAD.
CNN IS LEARNING THE JANUARY 6th
SELECT COMMITTEE HAS SUBPOENAED
PHONE RECORDS FROM MORE THAN 100
PEOPLE, INCLUDING FORMER WHITE
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF MARK
MEADOWS.
JAMIE GANGEL JOINS US WITH THE
CNN EXCLUSIVE.
HAS THE COMMITTEE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL WITH ANY OF THESE
SUBPOENAS?
HAVE THEY GOTTEN HOLD OF THESE
PHONE RECORDS?
>> WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT A BATCH
WENT OUT AND A BATCH HAS COME
BACK.
THERE'S ANOTHER BATCH OUT.
SO WE KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
REQUESTED MORE THAN 100 AND THEY
CERTAINLY HAVE GOTTEN A GROUP OF
THOSE RECORDS BACK.
I WANT TO EXPLAIN WHAT THE CALL
DETAIL RECORDS ARE.
IT IS NOT THE SUBSTANCE OF THE
PHONE CALLS.
IT'S NOT A RECORDING.
IT IS NOT THE SUBSTANCE OF A
TEXT MESSAGE, BUT IT TELLS YOU
WHO CALLED WHOM, AT WHAT TIME,
FOR HOW LONG.
WHO TEXTED ANOTHER PERSON.
SO NOW WHAT THEY DO IS THEY TAKE
THESE CALL DETAIL RECORDS AND
PERHAPS THEY CAN BUILD A WEB OF
COMMUNICATION ON THE DAY OF
JANUARY 6th.
ALTHOUGH THE TIMING GOES FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AT LEAST ONE
RECORD WE SAW THAT THEY
REQUESTED CALL DETAIL RECORDS
GOING BACK TO NOVEMBER 1st, JUST
BEFORE THE ELECTION, THROUGH THE
END OF JANUARY.
>> AND YOU HAVE NEW REPORTING ON
MARK MEADOWS.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE?
>> SO THIS IS BRAND-NEW JUST IN
TO CNN.
WE KNOW THAT HE IS NOW NOT
COOPERATING.
AND IF YOU LOOK CLOSELY AT THE
COMMITTEE'S STATEMENT, THEY
MENTION AND REMIND US THAT HE
HAS VOLUNTARILY ALREADY HANDED
OVER, WITH NO CLAIM OF
PRIVILEGE, WE KNOW MORE THAN
6,000 PAGES OF DOCUMENTS.
WHAT CNN HAS LEARNED TODAY, A
SOURCE WITH KNOWLEDGE HAS TOLD
ME THAT IN THOSE 6,000 PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS ARE HIS COMMUNICATIONS
ON JANUARY 6th AS THE RIOT WAS
UNFOLDING.
WITH NO CLAIM OF PRIVILEGE.
SO WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHO HE
WAS COMMUNICATING WITH ON
JANUARY 6th.
BUT THE COMMITTEE NOW HAS THIS
INFORMATION, AND, AS YOU AND I
KNOW, A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE MARK
MEADOWS' TELEPHONE NUMBERS SO
LET'S JUST THINK ABOUT WHO MIGHT
HAVE BEEN CALLING HIM AND
TEXTING HIM AND EMAILING HIM.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS, RALLY
ORGANIZERS, TRUMP LOYALISTS,
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, SOME
REPORTERS.
THE COMMITTEE HAS THOSE RECORDS.
>> WOW.
THAT'S INTENSE.
JAMIE GANGEL, THANKS FOR THAT.
>>> LET'S BRING IN ZOE LOFGREN.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
LET'S START WITH THE PHONE
RECORDS SUBPOENAED BY YOUR
PANEL.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY ARE YOU
LOOKING TO FIND BY GOING THIS
ROUTE?
>> DETAILS.
AS YOU KNOW, THIS IS A GIGANTIC
PUZZLE.
WE'VE GOT MANY PIECES AND WE
NEED TO PUT SOME MORE PIECES
TOGETHER, AS YOUR REPORTER
EXPLAINED.
THIS IS NOT THE CONTENT ANY OF
TEXT OR PHONE CALL.
IT'S TIME, PLACE, IT'S DATA.
REALLY IT'S METADATA, AND IT
WILL HELP US PUT TOGETHER THE
PICTURE.
BY THE WAY, MARK HAS SENT OVER
VOLUMES OF MATERIAL, INCLUDING
REALTIME COMMUNICATION AS THE
RIOT UNFOLDED WITHOUT AN
ASSERTION OF PRIVILEGE.
THE COMMITTEE WANTS TO ASK HIM
ABOUT SOME OF THAT, AND IT'S
REALLY UNTENABLE THAT ALL OF A
SUDDEN AT THE LAST MINUTE HE'S
SAYING NO, THAT SOMEHOW THERE'S
SOME REASON WHY HE CAN'T TALK
ABOUT THIS.
ESPECIALLY AFTER HIS BOOK IS
OUT.
APPARENTLY.
I HAVEN'T READ IT YET BUT FROM
REPORTS RECOUNTING CONVERSATIONS
HE HAD DIRECTLY WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
HE'S REPORTING ON THAT IN HIS
BOOK FOR MONEY, BUT REFUSING TO
TALK TO THE COMMITTEE ABOUT IT.
THAT'S UNTENABLE.
>> IF YOU GET THE METADATA FROM
A PHONE COMPANY THAT SUGGESTS,
LET'S SAY INDIVIDUAL A TALKED --
TEXTED INDIVIDUAL B AND YOU
THINK YOU CAN BUILD A CASE, YOU
THINK THAT MAY BE VERY INTEGRAL
TO YOUR INVESTIGATION, CAN YOU
THEN GO TO A JUDGE AND SEEK THE
CONTENT OF THAT TEXT MESSAGE?
>> SURE.
SURE.
IF THERE'S PROBABLE CAUSE TO DO
THAT.
THERE'S A BASIS FOR DOING THAT.
BUT, BY THE WAY, WHEN THERE'S A
TEXT EXCHANGE, THERE'S MORE THAN
ONE PARTY WHO HAS THE TEXT.
AND WE HAVE HAD MORE THAN 275
WITNESSES COME INTO THE
COMMITTEE ALREADY.
WE'VE HAD MORE THAN 30,000
DOCUMENTS PRODUCED TO US AND
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF TIPS
THAT HAVE COME IN.
SO WE ARE COMPILING INFORMATION.
THERE'S NO SINGLE WITNESS THAT
HAS ALL OF THE INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE SEEKING TO OBTAIN.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE ARE THINGS WE
WANT TO LEARN FROM MARK MEADOWS,
BUT WE'RE GETTING INFORMATION
FROM A VARIETY OF SOURCES.
>> HAVE YOU ESTABLISHED IN ANY
WAY YET THAT THE ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL WAS PREPLANNED BY
INDIVIDUALS EITHER IN THE WHITE
HOUSE OR WITH CLOSE CONNECTIONS
TO THE WHITE HOUSE DURING THE
TRUMP YEARS?
>> I DON'T WANT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION AT THIS POINT BECAUSE
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
BUT LET ME JUST SAY THERE'S
PLENTY LEFT TO INVESTIGATE AND
WE FOUND A VERY IMPORTANT
EVIDENCE SO FAR.
>> ANOTHER TRUMP ALLY, STEVE
BANNON, FACES AN UPCOMING TRIAL
AFTER FIGHTING HIS SUBPOENA FROM
YOUR COMMITTEE BOTH FOR
TESTIMONY AND FOR DOCUMENTS.
BANNON HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WANTED A
TRIAL TO START IN MID-APRIL.
THE BANNON TEAM PUSH FORWARD
OCTOBER 2022.
TODAY A JUDGE SEEMED TO SETTLE
THAT DISAGREEMENT AND HE SET THE
DATE FOR JULY 18th, 2022.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO HIS
LEGAL STRATEGY?
>> TO BANNON'S LEGAL STRATEGY?
>> YEAH.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF THERE IS ONE.
OBVIOUSLY, HE'D LIKE TO STAY OUT
OF PRISON FOR AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE.
YOU ALWAYS HOPE FOR EARLY TRIAL
DATES.
JUSTICE DELAYED IS JUSTICE
DENIED, BUT A JULY TRIAL DATE
MEANS THAT HE WILL BE FACING THE
MUSIC MID NEXT YEAR AND I THINK
THAT'S APPROPRIATE.
>> BANNON HAS BEEN ALL IN ON
THIS STRATEGY OF TRUMP
SUPPORTERS INFILTRATING LOCAL
REPUBLICAN PARTY POSTS.
IN AN INTERVIEW BANNON TOLD SARA
MURRAY, IT'S ABOUT WINNING
ELECTIONS WITH THE RIGHT PEOPLE,
MAGA PEOPLE.
WE'LL HAVE OUR PEOPLE IN AT
EVERY LEVEL, UNQUOTE.
YOUR COMMITTEE IS REVIEWING HOW
THE INTERSSURRECTION UNFOLDED BO
YOU THINK FOR TRUMP SUPPORTERS,
JANUARY 6th WAS ALSO A LESSONS
LEARNED FOR TEAM MAGA?
IN OTHER WORDS, THE SAFEGUARDS,
THE GUARDRAILS HELD BARELY
DURING THE LAST ELECTION, BUT DO
YOU THINK THE TRUMP TEAM ALSO
LEARNED, OKAY, THIS IS WHAT WE
NEED TO DO SO THAT NEXT TIME WE
CAN OVERTURN THE ELECTION?
>> WELL, I THINK WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IN THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE IS ABOUT DEFENDING
DEMOCRACY.
WHAT STEPS DO WE NEED TO TAKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S THE VOTES
AND THE VOICES OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT DETERMINE OUR
FUTURE, NOT A CABAL THAT WANTS
TO INSERT OR OVERTURN THE
VOTERS' DESIRES WITH THEIR OWN
QUEST FOR POWER.
THAT'S WHAT ULTIMATELY THIS IS
ABOUT.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT THE FACTS
AND WHAT HAPPENED ON THE 6th,
BUT ALSO TRYING TO I